six one seven eight three zero 47 50 is
the number we have time for I mean the
phone we we've got 12 callers on hold
right now and I think I may only have
time for one more call but let's go to I
don't know what do you think Pat if we
go to the 5-1 501 area code this is
unlikely to be one of your friends I
think probably okay caller what's your
name where are you calling from and
what's on your mind is Anthony from
Morrilton Arkansas great what's going on
well I wanted to ask y'all about shelled
opinion on the new hiring at TYT no I
know so I had a second segment last week
calling you out Sargon's clickbait video
hmm and Reese and over the weekend TYT
hired black lives matter worker Shawn
King I don't know if he's a worker or a
leader what he is but yeah he's a high
ranking in the black lives matter
movement I mean this what now I want a
word of rank let me well I'll answer
your question to the best I can which is
not that much because I don't know
what's going on over there but what are
the ranks in black lives matter I really
I don't know I'm not a member of black
law doesn't matter but you know Shaun
King is high rank under center well a
lot of people say was like that's my
ranking eyes yeah you know say he's a
George Soros Hill and whatnot uh-huh
beside that a lot of people giving them
a lot Jim T watching a lot of flack
right on line would you say would you
say it was a smart decision and hiring
him listen I know very little about
Shaun King and part of the reason I the
only thing I know about Shaun King is
that he blocked me on Twitter and I have
no idea why I've never had any exchange
with him my suspicion is I must have
gotten on some block list related to I
only I can only think I'm speculating
here but a gamergate block list and it
led to Shaun King blocking me but I know
nothing about him other than people he's
he's someone who blocked me on to it
and has been hired by t by t YT and so I
don't really know I can't comment I mean
what's the argument that he's a bad hire
why are t whitey taking flak for it
well he's he pretended to be black she's
like Rachel Dolezal okay I don't know I
don't know anything about that I have no
idea what his race is or what purported
races or actually I just don't know
about it well if you look at this
picture to see the bald shaved head take
the black and white photos has a goatee
and makes himself look as black as he
can and if the one were to what is the
how can you tell he's making himself
look african-american how can you tell
just you can look at normal pictures
that aren't black and white of him and
see that is to you this clearly
Caucasian so that you're saying is that
by taking pictures that are colorized
and making them black and white he's
deliberately attempting to look
african-american but he's actually white
that's that's what your salute lee well
listen it's all fascinating i have no
clue about any of it but it's it's
interesting and just to be clear to the
audience i don't know what this is about
and but it's interesting i don't know
what else I can say I'll check into it
alright but I do a pretty sure to call
and I just don't know too too much about
it alright well that was that was
interesting I really don't know about
that I know that sargon of akkad in a
video I made you know what this is like
a YouTube only drama that didn't even
make it onto the show right so I won't
even get into it but you can check out
my video about
TYT and Sargon on YouTube alright that's
it for calls we will take a break it is
inauguration day it is a dark day but it
is a day where you can sign up and
support independent media at david
pakman.com slash membership